I can’t wait to move into Gridiron Heights!
You guys are all f--king mistakes.
We’re here! Starters first!
KNEEL BEFORE ME, ROOKIE SCUM!
Nick!
Buddy, you know I’m coming back.
Ok, well, thanks, everyone. This was SO much fun while it lasted.
Gridiron Heights has never been stronger.
Rebuilding is so fun.
Helmet to helmet!
Yeah, we’re not rebuilding.
Yes you are.
I can clearly see you restructuring everything.
Yeah, no. Nothing’s changed.
We’re still really good.
Jimmy, are you going to help me?
Nah, just build around me.
Finally! Our rebuild is over.
Hey! I’m not hurt this time!
Soon enough, Sammy.
Just hit the nail, Hue.
The nail may not get hammered....
...but Browns fans certainly will.
The Patriots do not rebuild...
We reload.
Um, Coach, are we cool?
No.
Coach, ​t​hese plays are from before they invented the forward pass.
Why is every guy on our team 40 years old?
I'll tell you what man, you modern players with your personal brands and your screen passes.
Sometimes I wish I could just go back in time, man. Ooo-
Thanks for paying for the time machine instead of Khalil Mack.
Oh, of course, Jonnie! I love chasing the past!
Bring me back to when football was football and men were men, man.
2002!
Same office, same haircut
Wait... I know you man.
Coach, it’s me, Rich Gannon.
I tell yah what, a reliable quarterback I don’t have to pay...
I went back in time, man!
Hey, Coach Gruden!
Clean tackle!
Can’t wait to practice all offseason with no restrictions!
I am in heaven!
Oh hi, Coach! Have you met our terrible backup yet?
Hello. I’m Thomas-
Whoops!
Hahaha, thank goodness for the Tuck Rule.
Even clumsy rookie idiots can drop the ball...
and it’s still not a fumble!
MARK, YOU GOT TO BRING ME BACK TO 2018, MAN!
Tight Ends who block, Shrek, commit to the run game...
I’m sorry: But his brain is trapped in 2002.
FOREVER!
And that’s the Raider way!
Mike, please don’t leave me here, bro.
Tellus, you’re retired.
It’s not safe for you to be on your own.
I’m a year younger than you.
I’ll come visit...
Maybe during my bye week.
That’s not till Week 9...
Brothers never visit.
So it’s pretty neat here.
You can help the retired Cowboys call bingo games.
Ok, so based on this formation...
I’m guessing the next ball will be N24.
What he said!
Um...hey, Witt.
Oh...
It’s Marty.
When I moved into the retirement home...
crime dropped 100 percent!
Here we see our exercise programs.
My in-season record is 25,000...
but I think I can beat that now!
I’m sure Canada will call soon, T.O.!
They still think they can play...
This place sucks.
I gotta get the f--k out of here.
Martellus, you’re 31.
There’s nothing out there for you anymore.
One of us... One of us...
I survived a 28-3 deficit—
I’m not going out like this!
Cutty, I need help!
Cigarette?
There we go miscommunicating again.
AHHHHHH!!
♪ Retired Athletes Have No Life. ♪
I’ve assembled the greatest con men in the NFL
Do just well enough to get the money
then your talent disappears
But Fitzy, you’ve stolen millions
from the Rams, Bengals, Bills, Titans, Texans, Jets
What else is there?
I’m going to steal the starting QB job for the Bucs
Here’s the plan
I cause a distraction in the media
Ahem-
I went to Harvard
but I’m wearing silly clothes
Wow! Look!
Next we need a QB controversy
That’s where Sammy Sleeves comes in
Whoops
maybe you should start the rookie!
Dalton, Marvin
I need you to get people excited
but still lose a Wild Card game
The AFC North is really up for grabs
At this point
no one will know what it takes to be an NFL quarterback
And if I play one good half, I’ll get the job
Now eventually, I'll be exposed
Uh, sir
you’re going to want to see this
Only I get to be overpaid
Get him!
Tannehill
that’s when you confuse everybody
Uhhhhhhhh-
they are 3-0 uhhh
And they’ll have to start me anyway
Any questions?
Why don’t we just play great football all the time?
Because that’s so hard
WOOHOO!!!!
Hey, Aaron, is it just me, or
is this year’s Quarter-Season Carnival…
kinda soft?
Sir, you’re going to have to leave
Noooo
I love quarterbacks
I’m sorry
Hey look, guys
I finally hit the target!
I’m sorry
I know everyone’s rooting for me
Don’t worry
The Colts will help you win!
OH, I’M PATTY MAHOMES
AND I SHOOT REAL GOOD
Come ride Booger McFarland’s Sideline Machine!
WELL, THE CONDITIONS HERE
AT THE CARNIVAL ARE VERY SCARY
Sir, you’re up
Nope. Not yet.
Man, where’s Eli?
He said he’d connect with us here
HELP! I’M NOT A MOBILE QB!
I’M OLD AND SCARED
God damn-
Odell, you’re polite now, remember?
I love dealing with Eli
I can’t move my feet!
ELI! WHERE ARE YOU?!
I won’t leave my corn pocket
A PASS-RUSHER
LOOKING FOR A PASS-RUSHER!
ANY QUARTERBACKS!
I’M LOOKING FOR ANY
NON-CONTROVERSIAL QUARTERBACKS!
ANYBODY ON THE STEELERS!
WHERE YOU AT!
Shhhhhhh
Don’t tell
No siree, Bob
that maze is too tricky for me!
WOW, WHAT A FUN, EASY MAZE
After a loss, do you ever feel...
invisible?
No
mostly because people are always
extremely mean to me
I was like yo
I’ll never grab that ring
but my God
have you seen my STATS?
Whoa, pros only
Remember...
the Titans?
Oh yeah…that’s right, the Titans
I forgot about them
We lost to the Bills
and nobody knows we exist
Yeah, we should be household names
right Corey Davis?
Correct, Derrick Henry
We need a makeover for the
Gridiron Heights homecoming dance
I heard you’re looking for a culture change
Well, I used to play linebacker
WHOAAAA. SO RELATABLE.
First, we’re gonna touch you guys up
with some underperforming Patriots
Next, we’ll give you a whole new look
Wow! Two-tone gray sleeves!
Lastly…
it’s all in the attitude
Here
We go for it on 4th down now
So we’re basically the same team-
-That fired our coach after winning a playoff game
-And made slight roster changes
We’re beautiful!
Where are the Titans?
I need them to beat me one more time this year
Hi…
Look at those unis
Whoa
that’s a true big-market team
if I’ve ever seen one
Wow, the Rams got hot over the summer
Odell said I’m a murderer?
Haha, well that’s just our relationship, you know?
I mean, it’s not like
you can draft a QB over Saquon!
Yeah, I think they probably should have
Look, I love the fans
I would never harm a fan
But do I think they protect Eli?
YEAH, WELL HOW MANY RINGS HAS ODELL GIVEN US?
Eli won two Super Bowls against us
So now they are stuck with him forever
Rumors are, there’s tension
Eli, can you pass more to your best receiver?
No. We must only checkdown.
No comment! No comment!
But yes, I am loving this
BEN, GET OVER HERE
YOU WON’T BELIEVE WHAT GRUDEN DID NOW
Yeah, we don’t even need to be good
to win this division anymore
Look, I barely killed the Giants!
I’m not capable!
Coach, I’m here to bail you out again
OK, sorry, I have to have my family
yell at the Maras
Goodbye
What the hell did I do?
Ruined the Giants, of course
Matty, with only three wins
I don’t feel safe
We have no defense
Don’t worry, Julio
after the incident
I created a state-of-the-art panic room!
Wow, I can freak out about not scoring here!
Are you always stressing
that your 30-point games aren’t enough?
You need a panic room today
I THINK I MISSED MY SUPER BOWL WINDOW
See?
Season going poorly?
Panic with us!
WE BLEW A 17-POINT LEAD?
Oh, that’s perfect. I’ll take it.
I talk a lot of s--t
but my offense f--king sucks
MOTHER
Oh, I don’t need one
My brain is sort of like my own panic room
Our rooms come equipped
with a place to tweet frustrations
a schedule to stress about
WE PLAY THE RAMS AND THE PATS?!
and podiums for you to insist
you’re not panicking at
I actually feel really good
about where we’re at
Thank you
What if I just want to give up?
Luckily for you
we have “accepted defeat” rooms
I'M NOT CRYING
YOU'RE CRYING
Each comes with a Larry Fitzgerald
to make it all better!
It’s OK if your team is garbage
as long as everyone loves you!
God, he’s so classy
So buy today!
Because the season isn’t even halfway over
Ahhh!!!
It’s pretty awesome no one can mess with
us STARTING quarterbacks anymore
Sure, Sure, Yeah, yeah, right
Out of the way, Von
It’s a quarterback’s game now
God, I hate those pretty boys
Brock, wait up
I just wanted to say I’m really proud of you
This is the commencement of
The Annual Gridiron Heights Purge
At the siren, any and all penalties
including roughing the passer
will be legal
IT FEELS GOOD TO BE BAD
IT’S LIKE THE NFL FOUR YEARS AGO
IN HERE!
I’m allowed during the purge!
Oooooh! The purge looks fun!
It’s dangerous out there!
They’re celebrating with hip thrusts!
Oh my God, he’s mimicking a weapon!
And he’s wearing fun cleats to play
and not just as a pregame warm-up!
This is anarchy
We need to get to Matt Ryan’s panic room
THE REAL PURGE IS MENTAL, OK?!
NO PURGE IS PURGIER THAN THE PURGE
YOU’RE GOING THROUGH UP HERE OK
BREAK
OK
Cool
Thanks for that
You must love the purge, Vontaze
What’s the purge?
Baker!
I got purged
Coach, no!!!
Save yourselves
SCRAMBLE!
Trick or treat!
Here’s a treat
an extra-long episode of Gridiron Heights!
Wow!
Yay!
Told ya this neighborhood rules
Checkdown to be safe
Checkdown to- OOF
I DON’T THINK I CAN KEEP
UP WITH YOUS ALL
Well, yeah
We’re almost there!
Well, I guess there’s still the wild card
The purge is my cheat day
Sorry I have to sack you
No, that’s OK!
Great sack!
Great job being sacked!
JJ, look
I’m having a good season!
I HATE CHARITY
THE MONEY IS ALL MINE NOW!
GOOD JOB!
NOW BRING ME MORE HEADS, BOYS
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS TO US?!
Don’t you see all the good the purge does?
It lets the defense get out their aggressions
Hey, can we stay with you?
The StubHub Center is hosting
a flipping soccer practice
Sorry, man, we’re in mourning
I let down my fantasy teams again!
Nobody fluffin respects us!
We’re the GD front-runners
for an AFC Wild Card!
Bruh, where are we?
KIKO!!
K-K-K-K-KIKO!
Welcome to the Florida section
of Gridiron Heights!
How have I never noticed this place?
Probably because it’s only for
underperforming teams with
with quarterback controversies
And bath salts!
Let me give you a tour—
I’ll take it from here
Since I’m the most Florida person
you’ll ever meet—
AHHHH!
And I’m back
Over here we have our own hospital
Why aren’t we getting better?!
Guess you needanother year to evaluate me!
And that’s where the Jags D practices
OK, why am I the only one who showed up?
That’s our house!
Woah
We built it in ‘72 and
have sort of coasted since then
So where do you guys want to eat?
P-Rivs, let’s go home
Stay!
You can be the Kissimmee Chargers
and play inside the Medieval Times!
We need stars here
We’ve been starting a manatee
at left tackle for years
L.A. CAN KISS MY TUCKUS!
I’M STAYING HERE!
But we just signed a thousand-year lease!
I’M MAKING ANOTHER CULTURE CHANGE
EVERYONE, OUT
Yeah, OK, let’s leave
Coach, our flight to Mexico City
doesn’t leave for another 10 hours!
Hey, you gotta be prepared for everything
I DID IT AGAIN
I DIDN’T LEAVE ENOUGH TIME
GO. GO. GO.
HURRY
WOW, NO TRAFFIC!!!!
Let’s practice the Spanish I made you all learn
Dónde esta la end zone?
Aqui esta la end zone
LEAVE ALL YOUR STUFF
WE’LL GET MORE KANSAS CITY
BARBECUE IN MEXICO
Yo, I hope it’s cool
but I have like 20 carry-ons
I’m detecting a lot of weapons
HEY EVERYBODY, THE CHIEFS ARE HERE!
I think we have two potentially explosive offenses
RPO! RPO!
ATTENTION
THE GAME IN MEXICO CITY
THE FLIGHT IS LEAVING RIGHT NOW
Better hurry
I think I have a game script for this somewhere
I have the perfect play
Oh God, they’re both so innovative
Hey man, we’re the same!
We’re both front-runners!
I am very clearly in front of you
We made it!
HELL YEAH! LET’S GO!
Come on, Travis, get on the plane
MAN, TRAVELING IS SO STRESS-FREE
LOOK AT ALL THIS LEG ROOM!
MY DEFENSE!
Always an afterthought
Welcome to dinner for all the teams
who have to play on Thanksgiving!
I brought my famous green bean casserole
It’s pretty good, but it’s not gonna win any awards
I wish we could go out to the bar
tonight like the other teams
ELI, IT’S BEEN YEARS!
HOW YOU BEEN, MAN?!
We’re undefeated in November!
YO, JAMES CONNER IS DOING KARAOKE!
We’ve got some exciting news in the middle
of this Gridiron Heights episode
PS4 and VR Bundles are starting at $199
during Black Friday week!
GOBBLE, GOBBLE
Taysom, more pepper!
Hey man, let me take that
I think you’re finished
Pass this around to Khalil
Just pass left, Mitchell
A toast!
We may not see all of you next year—
Wait, what?
But we love coming together
To friendly competition!
Careful, Matt, don’t choke
WHERE’S DREW’S MVP, SEAN?!
SIT UP STRAIGHT
BE FANCY AND PROFESSIONAL LIKE ME
Hey, Stafford, you want seconds?
Uh, sure
I’m Colt McCoy
and I’m still the most popular quarterback in Texas
THE NFC EAST COULD BE MINE
INTERCEPTION
I BLAME THE FANS
TAYSOM, START THE CAR
Already done, sir
Hey, what exactly is Taysom Hill’s job?
NOBODY KNOWS
I could kick Dan Quinn’s ass
I’m good now
Happy Thanksgiving
Hey T.Y.!
Just calling to make sure everything’s A-OK!
Yeah, Andrew, you called five minutes ago.
I’m fine-
Wait, someone’s coming for the AFC South.
But I was only hurt for three years!
OK, T.Y., go deep.
The next part is very important.
They're gonna take the division.
AAHHHHHHH! I SEE TEXANS-
EIGHT STRAIGHT WINS!
THEY SAY THEY HAVE A NUKE!
DESHAUN WATSON!
Oh golly!
I don't know who you are
I don't know what you want
but I’m Andrew.
Hello!
I have a very particular set of skills
skills I have acquired over almost half a career.
Skills like accuracy
good decision-making
and recommending the perfect book.
Sorry for evading you!
Good try though!
So close!
Skills that make me a nightmare
for people like you
and I’m sorry about that.
I need you to be focused!
So we all play our best!
HE’S GOING TO TORCH OUR DEFENSE!
If you let the AFC South go now
that'll be the end of it!
Oh boy, what kind of a person would
hang out in a gross place like this?
Oh, hello Mr. Irsay!
Andrew, man, I like you, man.
But if you don't
I will look for you
I will find you
you silly goose
and I will absolutely destroy you.
Uh, I can’t tell if he’s threatening us or not.
Hi guys!
You forget how mobile he is.
Get him!
I have cover now!
AAAAAAAHHHHHHH!
Gather round for the Week 14 playoff picture!
How do you all like your sweaters?!
Oh they're so good.
I LOVE IT!
Get out of my way, Mahomes—
HEY!
IF YOU ALL COULD JUST BEHAVE
I’LL BUY YA’LL GD FRENCH FRIES
AT THE FUDGING FOOD COURT.
Welcome to the Saints.
The first rule of Drew Brees
is you don’t talk about Drew Brees.
The second rule of Drew Brees
is that when you do talk about him
you mention that he’s a great football player
but an even better man.
He’s so nice.
Like many of you, I was stuck.
I’d go through 7-9 seasons and wonder
“How do these consistent passing records
define me as a person?”
I’d pray for a different life.
I want you to line up as a receiver.
What?
I want you.
To line up.
As a receiver.
What if we did wacky stuff on offense all the time?
Thus began Project Mayhem.
Did you go for it on 4th down?
Which f--king time?
Someone beat the Rams
and the question everyone is asking...
who dat?
Our offense is getting too dangerous.
We have to stop this.
Sorry sir,
we must do everything to completions.
His name was Desmond Bryant.
I’m coming back.
Coach, Taysom Hill is taking over.
He’s running, he’s passing, he’s blocking, he’s-
That’s impossible!
Nobody like that exists.
You were looking for a way
to stop being boring and great,
so you made me up
so you could be interesting and great.
Everything’s going to be fine.
I promise.
Hey everyone,
welcome to the Gridiron Heights Christmas party!
Keep in mind layoffs are coming.
Oh no.
I’m freaking out.
No. No. No.
I’m not being replaced.
I’m still hurt.
See!
OW!
Santa Gruden,
I’m giving all my players away, OK?
And an Amari for you.
WOAH, A RECEIVER!
I’ve never had one before.
Hey, who wants a Derek Carr?!
Hey, how about you, Dan Snyder, man?
He’s only $125 million?!
Oh, can I, Jerry?
Please?!
OK, Odell, this is a work event.
Behave yourself.
WOOO!
I HAVE STRONG OPINIONS ABOUT ALL OF YOU!
That’s a fine-
HEY, WOAH WOAH ZEKE, I’LL FINE YOU TOO-
THANK YOU.
I just came to get my stuff.
You’re having a party without me?
I’m having the time of my life.
I’m back!
Gronk may be too old for this.
OK, the NFC's a mess.
YEAH IT IS.
Where’s Eli?
Oh, he’s babysitting.
PEW! PEW!
LET’S PRETEND PLAYOFFS!
NO!
I’M GOING FOR REAL!
IF YOU GUYS DON’T GO TO BED,
SANTA WON’T COME.
I’M TALL, BUT I CAN RUN.
WHY ARE THESE KIDS SO MOBILE?!
Another year without the postseason…
Dear God, or the Dalai Lama or whatever,
I don’t know, I’m still searching-
Please show me the way.
JORDY NELSON?!
Now I hope you weren’t trying to tank.
Tanking’s a sin.
No, but sometimes I wish
I was just never even drafted at all.
That’s an idea.
What do you think, Vince Lombardi?
OK. I agree.
You’ve never been drafted.
Hey, my leg stopped hurting-
What.
I’m 49 years old
and I’m still the quarterback of the Packers.
Without you, Brett Favre wouldn’t leave.
The Packers haven’t won a game in 10 years.
State Farm shut down.
Nobody was here to discount double check.
The Bears won that 2010 NFC championship.
I’m Jay Cutler, and I never give up.
Clay! Clay, don’t you know me?
HELP! THIS MAN IS SCARING ME!
JORDY! GET ME BACK.
I want to be on the Packers again!
Hey Aaron-
Hey, watch your-
MY LEG’S HURTING, BRETT!
MY LEG’S HURTING!
MERRY CHRISTMAS GREEN BAY!
Aaron!
The owner’s going to make changes!
We are going to hire someone
with imaginative play-calling!
Every time a whistle blows
the Packers still have
more rings than the Bears.
We’re gonna have to do the shuffle again.
Shuff-shuffle again. Do the shuffle again.
2019, it’s the shuffle remix.
Reminisce cause we missed '85, '86.
Leader of the offense.
The defense is so fresh,
I’m in the NFL
and I just learned how to throw left.
I can scramble, I can run
I can throw touch passes.
And I’m livin’ in the city with the
most mustaches.
Nagy can nag me
but don’t call me Mitch.
And my name ain’t Jay Cutler
so don’t call me-
Whatever?!
Go to Club Dub.
We all got up in
bringing back '86 with the shuffle again.
Last name Cohen
so I get a bar mitzvah.
And I got a new sweater
so I’m dressed like Mike Ditka.
And we don’t mean this is a mean way
Cheese-eating hillbillies
all live in Green Bay.
D-D-D-DEFENSE!!!!!!!
Check the movement
monsters of the midway
defense superhuman.
Never losin’, and we get stupid
stupid like when I was traded by Gruden.
Turn a player to a hater
when I hit a player
QB incinerator
imitator of refrigerator.
HICKS.
FULLER.
JACKSON.
Defense killin’.
And I’m worth 2 first-round draft picks
and $141 million.
In 2019, take it back to '86.
When we win, we’ll do
the Super Bowl Shuffle remix.
Hopefully.
Listen up, gentlemen.
You morons may have only let me win 11 games.
We suck. We're...
NOT GETTING MINNESOTA MIRACLE’D
BY THE F--KING EAGLES THIS—
year may be Jared’s last chance
before we replace him
with another cheap rookie.
I’m sorry, what?
I SAID I DON’T EVEN LOOK WHEN I THROW.
WOO-HOO! YEAH!
Settle down
I know everyone is depressed
because we’re a two seed
but we have to stick together.
Gilmore
what happens when we're
five seconds late to a meeting?
We get yelled at till we cry?
And Gronk
remember when you were
unhappy with the team?
PATRIOTS TRIED TO TRADE GRONK
AFTER THEY BROKE GRONK’S BODY.
And Josh Gordon, remem-
Oh right. We have no—
RECEIVERS MUST GET TACKLED
ON THE LAST PLAY OF THE—
game reminds me of the
1918 Dayton Triangles/Toledo Maroons game
where they had a secret—
weapon.
ANDY REID AFTER A BYE WEEK!!!
I HAVE TIME, BOYS!
HE’S BACK!
And yes
there’s stuff to worry about
like aging—
And Zeke
And the fact that
Bountygate clearly angered God
AND HURTING MY FRIEND THE FOOTBALL
BY THROWING IT TOO HARD.
BUT THIS IS OUR YEAR.
BIG NICK HERE TO DOUBLE DOINK EVERYONE!
- Oh Christ!
- Oh Muskrats!
Welcome to Elimination Creek Country Club.
I believe you know your way around, Dak.
Just give me a drink.
This sucks.
We are very depressed.
The club is nice.
I’m getting almost as much rest
as I did in the Wild Card Game.
Yeah.
Now all the charities
know I have free time....
FUDGE THE OFFSEASON!
I WANT FRICKIN' FOOTBALL!
Phil, Phil, PHIL, PHIL!
Can I just run it?
Hey, maybe I—
Sorry, sir.
Starters only at the club.
I’M ELITE.
I’ll be one of Washington’s
five starting quarterbacks next year.
Not again.
YOU GOT THIS.
NEVER CHOKE.
BELIEVE IN YOURSELF.
All right
well great season everyone.
See you next year! Much love.
By the way, man
I’m totally cool with outbursts.
So now that my fourth OC has left
I have to wonder
am I the problem?
CANNONBALL, hahaha!
Tough elimination, man.
That’s OK!
This time last year
I was legally dead lol.
BRING IT ON!
OH NO. MY POWER ZONE!
I’M TRANSFORMING BACK
TO REGULAR-SEASON NICK.
So the trick is to just have
your family yell at the owners—
OW, DADDY!
Must be the players on the
playoff course across the street.
Can you throw it back?
It’s only like 400 yards.
Why are you having fun?
This is a game.
Everyone here in Gridiron Heights
is gearing up for the only game
that truly matters:
the Pro Bowl.
AGAIN.
You boys didn’t practice for two whole days
to lose this game. AGAIN.
CLEAR EYES.
FULL HEARTS.
PRO BOWL!!!
Coach, I got the votes.
I can play.
Son, I am so proud of you.
You’re a Pro Bowl alternate.
Here’s to God
football
and the 2019 AFC Pro Bowl team.
AFC FOREVER!!!
You guys are my brothers.
Hey, I’m JuJu by the way.
I play for the Steelers.
- My name is Keenan Allen.
- Hi I’m Quenton Nelson.
- Nice to meet you.
Wow.
The Camping World Stadium in Orlando, Florida.
Doesn’t get much better than this.
They play the Citrus Bowl here...
OK boys, we’re just going to play
good ol’ half-speed football
with minimal tackling.
OH, I’M SO BUMMED
I CAN’T PLAY IN THIS BIG GAME.
WIN THIS FOR ME, SON.
Pro Bowls and memories.
That’s all you got.
YOU BEST PLAY 3!
YOU’RE EMBARRASSING ME, COACH.
3...you’re in.
Hut hut!
Wilson takes the snap.
Oh, Miller’s coming for him!
There you go. There you go.
Goodnight.
[Gasps]
We want to apologize to the millions
and millions of children
at home watching the Pro Bowl.
Smile!
For even in elimination
you have become children of Brady!
We have a 25-point lead.
Huh, I feel like people are
never going to let me get over this.
One more
and I’ll have just as many as the Steelers!
Thomas is coming.
You all in the AFC need to stop him.
If he wins again
it will be boring on a scale
this league has never seen.
Prepare the offense
engage all defenses
and get this man a coach
who can maximize his serviceable talent!
Hey, I’m a computer man.
Something’s wrong.
St. Louis is deserted.
All that’s left is baseball
and a Six Flags.
STAN KROENKE?!
WE HAD TO LEAVE ST. LOUIS!
IT’S A SMALL MARKET TOWN!
I need you to pay me.
It’s the only way to stop Brady.
It can’t be done!
You play defense!
RPO.
Is he OK?
OH, THAT’S JUST COACH
TRYING TO GAME PLAN.
Fun teams in the AFC?
I will restore order to the universe.
I’M GOING TO TAKE DOWN THE GOAT!
It’s working!
I see so many articles about how this
could be the end of the Patriots dynasty.
AH, FUDGING BRADY
STOPPING ME FROM BEING A G.D. H.O.F.-ER.
CALM DOWN, PHIL!
FUDGE.
In my experience
giving him back the ball is bad.
Jeez, we get it.
Oh hey, look—I got us to overtime!
Overtime rules.
Tom gets to punch first.
If he misses, Patrick gets to punch.
WAIT, I MIGHT NOT GET TO PLAY?!?!
Great competitor. Hell of a game.
We’re at the end of the game now!
The Rams are our last chance.
Me and the Rams had a bit of a falling out...
NO, I SHOULD WIN.
Oh, sorry! I didn’t see that.
STOP HOLDING OUT!
YOU’RE HURTING YOURSELF!
AHHHHHHHHH!
OK, Todd
now may be a good time to unleash
THE GURLEY!
AHHHHHHHHH!
Yo, something weird
is going on with me right now.
What are they?
White no-name position players.
Totally expendable.
ATTACK!
THIS OLD THING STILL WORKS!
HALLE BERRY!
I don’t even know who you are.
Jared’s a system quarterback
JUST LIKE YOU!
NOT TRUE!
You shouldn’t have gone for my head.
No!
Roughing the passer!
Oh fun!
A new setback!
I am Lamar!
I am…
AH, FLUFF-
Hell yeah, I get to disappear again!
MR. BREES
I DON’T FEEL SO GOOD.
I blame the refs
and I refuse to accept this reality.
OK, so that’s one of the 14 million ways
this could go down.
Let’s practice it again!
Ugh.
Thanos didn’t go far enough.